este domingo se cumple el primer mes del
golpe de estado militar de mianmar y ha
sido el día más letal y represivo por
parte de la junta militar los disparos
de fuego real contra manifestantes
dejaron numerosos fallecidos
organizaciones como human rights watch
lo condenan la clara escalada del uso de
la fuerza letal de las fuerzas de
seguridad de mianmar en varios pueblos y
ciudades de todo el país en respuesta a
manifestantes en su mayoría pacíficos
contra el golpe de estado es indignante
e inaceptable y debe tenerse de
inmediato más allá de los muertos las
detenciones ya se sitúan alrededor de
las 1000 personas entre los que se
encuentran múltiples periodistas como un
reportero de la agencia estadounidense
associated press human rigths watch
también instó al cese de estas
detenciones según las informes las
fuerzas de seguridad detuvieron a varios
periodistas que cubrían las protestas
deberían ser puestos en libertad de
inmediato y sin condiciones sin embargo
la represión no acalla las protestas
miles de personas salieron en distintas
ciudades del país
esta es la capital naypyidaw
esto es rangún
esto es the way y esto es manda line
los manifestantes piden la vuelta de la
democracia y la liberación de aung san
suu kyi líder del partido gobernante
antes del golpe la liga nacional por la
democracia han perdido el miedo
nos disparan soy consciente pero no me
importa ya me despedí de mi familia
antes de salir de casa en caso de que
por desgracia no pueda volver con el
aumento de la violencia la junta militar
trata de acallar el descontento social
además han destituido al crítico
embajador ante la onu mientras desoyen
los llamados internacionales de
reinstaurar la democracia